Travis Scott has just had his concert
canceled in Egypt who is Travis Scott I
don't really remember I only remember
him as being this kind of eccentric
popular musician who performs bizarre
occult rituals and uses satanic and
occult imagery in his public
performances overt image rate this is
not a satanic Panic looking for Devils
under every Rock and this is very overt
the stage for one of his concerts was
was a depiction of hieronymous Bosch's
you know uh hellish
images and he regularly uses this kind
of satanic language and and imagery so
anyway he was supposed to perform a
concert at the Giza Pyramid
and Egypt just said no
Egyptian authorities said no thank you
we don't want your weird occult satanic
stuff uh
since the general Syndicate is part of
the fabric of this Beloved Country it is
Keen on its stability and security and
refuses to tamper with societal values
and Egyptian and Arab customs and
traditions based on research and
documented information about strange
rituals at Travis's concerts that are
inconsistent with our authentic societal
values and traditions the board of
directors has decided to cancel the
license issued to hold this type of
concert that contradicts the cultural
identity of the Egyptian people very
based very good wonderful stuff and we
should
we should seek to emulate that sort of
thing in the West
similar to Trump saying a nice thing
about Xi Jinping
does it mean now that we want to model
our country after Egypt and the Muslim
leaders of Egypt no it doesn't but
they're right about this issue
just like Xi Jinping can be right about
a thing or two also
and in political humility we can look
toward other cultures and try to take
the best of what they're doing and try
to learn from them
and in the West in recent years the
occult imagery that is cropped up is so
bizarre and so over at Sam Smith dancing
around as a devil
all of this kind of imagery
it's much more prominent in the west
than it used to be and we we seem to
have lost the ability to say no to it
now we have Baphomet statues inside
public spaces inside government
buildings well in the name of religious
liberty now we have satanic clubs in
elementary schools we've reported on it
on this show before
openly overtly and why is this happening
because we in the liberal West have lost
the ability to say no and other nations
that many of the Liberals would deride
as authoritarian ironic because the
Liberals are much more authoritarian
than anybody else in the country
certainly more so than the conservatives
some of those other nations that have a
deeper political tradition and that look
a little deeper than consent as the
be-all and end all moral Criterion for
public policy and who recognize that
there are other things and other virtues
to take into account as well in policy
they just look at that and they say oh
no you got the satanic singer and he
wants to sing by the pyramid yet no
thanks that's not in line with our
values in Egypt
conservatives I think need to learn that
lesson we need to be able to say no
thanks religious liberty doesn't give
religious liberty certainly not as the
founders and framers understood it
doesn't give you any right to have a
Baphomet doll in a public space doesn't
give you a right to practice Satanism
doesn't give you a righteous satanic
Club in an elementary school doesn't
give you a right to perform all sorts of
other sick bizarre rituals that are
sometimes overtly occult and sometimes
are merely uh implicitly so in the weird
ideologies that the libs are forcing
everywhere especially in the month of
June
we should just say no to that and we
need to we need to figure out well on
what what grounds can we say now
liberalism
exalts
consent and individual autonomy Above
All Else and the consequence of that is
it erodes the cultural Foundation that
allowed it to operate in the first place
well what are we going to replace that
with as we think a little bit more
deeply about what it means to be a
conservative what it means to be an
American what it means to live in the
west which used to be known as
Christendom right now text Knowles to 98
98 98 we are days away from the Durbin
Accords the greatest threat to the US
Dollars Global dominance in the past 80
years
on August 22nd brics Nations that's
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa are expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the U.S and
the dollar is cornerstones of the Global
Financial system how can you protect
your IRA or 401k
from The Fallout from this Landmark
announcement now is the time to
diversify with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty that would
be right now when currencies fail gold
is a safe haven how much more time does
the Dollar have protect your savings
with gold Birch gold has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles Canada wies to 98 98 98 get your
free info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on again text nulls Canada wlas to 98.98
98. right now head on over to
karzing.com Knowles buying a new car can
be a stressful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first-time buyer
or have no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the entire day with
the crowd's stress and potential to it
not even find the right car you got to
check out Carson carzing is completely
changing the way you buy a car online
by partnering with Credit Agencies
lenders and over 25 000 dealers
Nationwide
coursing provides you with everything
you need before stepping foot onto a
dealership
once you find the right car for your
ideal budget all you've got to do is
bring your saved deal voucher with you
to the dealership to finalize your next
ride super simple even if you're not in
the market for a new car you should
check out carsing anyway coursing's
online window shopping experience goes
beyond mirror images you dive deep into
each vehicle's specifications features
and performance capabilities
zoom in on the craftsmanship of the
Interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology check out all the great stuff
about these cars carsing helps make your
experience faster cheaper less stressful
go to carson.com Knowles today find the
best deals near you that is carzing.com
Knowles
Marjorie green Republican congressman
just featured quite an obscene and
pornographic display in a house
Committee hearing
she was referring to the evidence that
was found on Hunter Biden's laptop which
showed that he paid a hooker out of his
law firm's bank account and she featured
semi-blocked out
semi-censored images of Hunter engaging
in weird sex acts with said hookers we
here at the daily wire at the Michael
Mills show have blurted out even further
this is a family program here is what
Congress lady green had to say
I will let the screen wrap up
five seconds and then uh I'll give Mr
mafume additional time thank you Mr
chairman
um Mr shapley you you saw an
investigation under Hunter Biden
codename Sportsman which opened in
November of 2018.
um it was an offshoot of an
investigation the IRS was conducting
into a foreign-based amateur online
pornography platform
um this this is evidence
of of Hunter Biden
excuse me this is my time making
pornography should we be displaying this
Mr chairman of the ladies
should we be displaying this Mr chairman
this is obscene this is pornographic you
hear the Democrat off camera yelling and
screaming and crying because Marjorie
green is showing censored pictures of
Hunter Biden engaging in an oral sex act
okay
fair enough liberals in the media
started whining immediately after the
Congress lady did this and I agree I
totally agree with the criticism it's
obscene it's pornographic
it has no place in the House of
Representatives
but unfortunately today those same
people who are raising all of those
objections
they're insisting that more graphic
displays of even more obscene and
depraved sexual acts belong in
Elementary School classrooms
because all those very same people who
are clutching their pearls how dare you
Congress lady green how dare you show a
censored picture of Hunter Biden
engaging in some sex acts those were the
same people are promoting genderqueer
the book by Maya kababi in Elementary
School classrooms and when conservatives
like Ron DeSantis go in and they say no
we're going to ban that book from
Elementary School classrooms because
it's depraved gay porn showing more
depraved versions of the same sex act
that Marjorie green showed censored as
Representatives they say that belongs in
kindergarten
that belongs in your Elementary School
library so can the Democrats please
explain to me
why this kind of pornography has no
place in the House of Representatives to
be viewed by adults as a as a matter of
debating National policy and National
political Scandal but it does belong in
the classroom of five-year-olds
in an even more obscene way why is that
something tells me they're being a
little disingenuous about their
opposition to pornography and obscenity
and the Pearl clutching
look man I'm all for it we have
obscenity laws on the books I think we
should enforce them we have a long
tradition in America of banning
pornographic and obscene materials I
think pornography is one of if not the
biggest
basically not spoken of social problems
in the country because it's ubiquitous
and it puts people in a state of
Perpetual mortal sin and it puts a huge
percentage of the population in that
state and it's very difficult it's
actually impossible to have a good
Republic
when you've got people constantly
engaging in Vice that's degrading so I'm
all for let's do it baby
let's ban this stuff from certainly from
the Congress let's ban it from all sorts
of places
but you want to put it into elementary
school so what the left tells me then is
it loves the obscenity it loves the
depravity it loves the pornography it
wants to present all of this stuff to
the most innocent people in our country
it just doesn't want to get caught
in the act of the consequences of that
depravity
the the country that presents porn
everywhere is the country that becomes a
nation of Hunter bidens that actually
does this stuff but they want to cover
up the consequences they want all of the
titillation they want all of the
degradation they just don't want to get
caught in their own depravity and
Corruption of course boy what a great
clip that was make sure that you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel don't miss
anything a clip an episode a two and a
half hour interview with the Q Anon
Shaman don't miss anything
see you then